(Mit zittriger Stimme)
Es ist ... ein Wechsel.
Der ist immer auch mit Emotionen
verbunden, wie Sie spüren.
Ich habe diese Arbeit
sehr gerne gemacht.
La Suisse vous dit merci.
Est elue avec 125 voix ...
- Gewählt ist mit 125 Stimmen ...
... Madame Widmer-Schlumpf.
Sie muss sich im Klaren sein:
Wenn sie zusagt,
ist sie in den Augen
vieler Wähler/-innen unserer Partei
eine Verräterin.
Ich schwöre es.
Guten Tag, meine Damen und Herren.
Wir müssen uns bewusst sein,
dass Frauen,
die nach Macht und Einfluss greifen,
eine Bedrohung
für die Macht der Männer darstellen.
(Mann) Micheline Calmy-Rey!
Je le promets.
Ich schwöre es.
(Frau) Frau Simonetta Sommaruga.
Ich erkläre Annahme der Wahl.
Schauen Sie bitte kurz her.
Sehr gut.
Frauen im Bundesrat:
Haben sie es schwerer als Männer?
Was machen sie anders?
Und wie unterscheidet sich
ihre Politik
von derjenigen ihrer Kollegen?
Zu Hause bei alt Bundesrätin
Elisabeth Kopp.
Kamillenblüten, ha!
Das ist ja geradezu
ein Erfolgserlebnis.
Passionierte Köchin, Frau Kopp?
- Das kann man nicht wirklich sagen.
Es macht auch keinen Spass,
für sich allein zu kochen.
Ich hatte einen Mann,
der leidenschaftlich gerne gut ass
und sich freute und sich bedankte,
wenn es etwas Gutes gab.
Dann macht es Spass.
Ihr Mann, Hans W. Kopp.
Vor neun Jahren ist er gestorben.
Ich sah ihn
und schon war es um mich geschehen.
Ich wusste nicht,
wie er heisst, wer er ist,
ich wusste nur,
wenn ich einen heirate, dann den.
Sie verloben sich am selben Tag.
Mit ihm wird sie hoch aufsteigen
und später tief fallen.
Est elue par 124 voix ...
Madame Kopp.
Ich weiss noch gut, als ich zur
Annahmeerklärung nach vorne ging,
dachte ich mir: "Du musst es einfach
in jeder Beziehung gut machen."
Dossiersicherheit sowieso,
aber auch sonst.
Ich wollte den Beweis antreten,
dass man nicht sagen kann:
"Eine Frau kann das nicht."
"Sie ist physisch oder psychisch
diesem Amt nicht gewachsen."
Das war mein Ziel.
Herr Präsident,
meine Damen und Herren,
ich kann Ihnen aus naheliegenden
Gründen nicht versprechen,
im Bundesrat meinen Mann zu stellen.
* Lachen *
Was ich Ihnen jedoch zusagen kann,
ist, dass ich alles tun werde,
um das, was als Frau und als Mensch
in mir steckt, aufzubieten.
In diesem Sinne
erkläre ich Annahme der Wahl.
Mit Elisabeth Kopp zieht 1984
erstmals eine Frau in den Bundesrat.
Eine bürgerliche Frau schafft,
was ein Jahr zuvor
der kämpferischen Sozialdemokratin
Lilian Uchtenhagen verwehrt wurde.
Es geht mir nicht nur um Grundsätze,
es geht mir auch um die Leute,
die heute leben.
Ich mache nicht Politik
auf dem Buckel dieser Leute.
... par 124 voix.
Herr Stich ist gewählt
mit 124 Stimmen.
Ich sage es deutsch und deutlich:
Die Männer hatten Angst vor ihr.
Sie sagten immer: "Wir wollen
eine Frau, aber nicht diese."
Wenn man fragte, warum, hiess es,
sie habe einmal aus lauter Wut
einen Aschenbecher an die Wand
geworfen oder zu heulen begonnen.
Ob das stimmt, weiss ich nicht.
Sie hat es immer bestritten.
Aber ich glaube,
es gab viele Männer,
die sich ihr
nicht gewachsen fühlten.
Und Sie waren einfacher zu handhaben?
Das dachten sie.
136 Jahre lang
regierten die Männer alleine.
117 Bundesräte kennt die Schweiz.
Und nur sieben davon waren weiblich.
Ruth Dreifuss war die zweite.
Vor zwei Wochen in Genf.
Wir treffen sie in ihrer Wohnung.
Ich wurde
bereits als Mädchen politisiert.
Ich würde sagen von ...
Ich würde sagen, fast von Geburt an.
1940, Zweiter Weltkrieg,
in einer jüdischen Familie.
Nicht weit von der deutsch-
österreichischen Grenze entfernt.
Das ist schon ein Anfang.
Ein Anfang des Bewusstseins,
was Politik bewirken kann.
Im März 1993 übernimmt
die frischgewählte SP-Bundesrätin
das Departement des Innern.
Alle einen Schritt zurück, bitte.
- Alle was?
Einen Schritt zurück.
Achtung!
Eigentlich hätte sie - die
Sozialdemokratin Christiane Brunner -
Bundesrätin werden sollen.
(Alle) Brunner, Brunner, Brunner!
Doch das Parlament
wählt zuerst diesen Mann.
Gewählt ist mit 130 Stimmen
Herr Nationalrat Matthey.
(Alle) Brunner, Brunner, Brunner!
SP-Nationalrat Matthey
lehnt die Wahl ab.
Die SP
hält an Christiane Brunner fest
und schlägt noch zusätzlich
Ruth Dreifuss vor.
Dann plötzlich Gerüchte, Christiane
Brunner habe für Nacktfotos posiert.
Das war
eine absolute Schlammschlacht.
Es stand überhaupt nichts dahinter.
Das waren nur Männerfantasien und
der Wille, der SP eins auszuwischen.
Ruth Dreifuss
hat die besseren Chancen.
Ich fürchte,
dass es zwei Gründe sind.
Und beide sind unannehmbar.
Ich denke, das Äusserliche.
Ich beruhige die Leute,
weil ich ein wenig bieder aussehe.
Das ist nur, weil es mich nicht
interessiert, wie ich aussehe.
Und das Zweite:
Ich entspreche genau einer Frau,
wie man sie in der Politik erwartet.
Ledig, keine Familie,
etwas zwischen Mann und Frau,
das alles geopfert hat
und dadurch vielleicht
Anspruch auf Anerkennung hat.
Und beides ist für mich
sehr schockierend.
(Mann) Stimmen haben erhalten:
Frau Dreifuss: 112 Stimmen.
Madame Dreifuss: 112 voix.
Frau Brunner: 86 Stimmen.
- Madame Brunner: 86 voix.
Was?
Zuerst war ich eher erschrocken
und traurig.
Es war nicht das,
was ich erwartet hatte.
Dann habe ich mit Freude
die Ärmel hochgekrempelt.
Es dauerte einen Tag,
bis mir bewusst wurde:
Jetzt gilt es, sich in die
verschiedenen Themen einzuarbeiten
und Beschlüsse freudig mitzutragen.
Gab es als Bundesrätin nie Momente,
in denen Sie in Ihrem Selbstvertrauen
verunsichert wurden?
Nein, sicher nicht.
Ich habe eher
meine Kollegen verunsichert.
Für sie war ich ein komisches Wesen
in diesem Gremium.
Sie mussten sich
zuerst daran gewöhnen,
so jemanden Exotisches
in ihren Reihen zu finden.
Von Zeit zu Zeit sagte ich,
ich hätte wirklich den Eindruck,
dass sie sich fragen: "Ist sie so,
weil sie eine Frau ist?"
"Weil sie welsch ist,
weil sie jüdischer Herkunft ist?"
"Was ist so komisch an diesem Wesen,
das wir nicht sofort verstehen?"
Alt Bundesrätin Ruth Metzler.
Wir treffen sie in Appenzell,
bei einer Freundin zu Hause.
Die damals jüngste Bundesrätin
ist heute 54 Jahre alt.
Frau Dreifuss und ich,
wir vertraten ja bei vielen Themen
nicht dieselbe Meinung,
aber wir hatten so etwas
wie eine persönliche Allianz,
ein persönliches Gespür, einen
persönlichen Zugang zueinander,
unabhängig davon, was wir
in der Sache selbst vertraten.
Die beiden Frauen
kennen sich seit 1996:
Ruth Dreifuss
ist an der Landsgemeinde dabei,
als der politische Aufstieg
von Ruth Metzler beginnt.
An der Landsgemeinde in Appenzell
wird die 32-Jährige
als erste Frau
in die Innerrhoder Regierung gewählt.
Ich bin sehr erfreut, dass
Damenwahlen zur Normalität werden.
Zwei Jahre später wird sie von
der CVP für den Bundesrat nominiert.
Gewählt ist mit 126 Stimmen:
Frau ...
Est elue avec 126 voix ...
Frau Ruth Metzler.
* Jubel *
Ich hoffe, Sie verstehen,
dass ich etwas überwältigt bin
von diesem Ereignis.
Ich freue mich.
Ich hoffe, dass ich das Vertrauen,
das in mich gesetzt wird,
auch erfüllen kann.
Es wird nicht immer einfach sein.
Wenn ich heute zurückblicke
und 34-Jährige sehe,
dann denke ich:
"Ja, da war ich wirklich mutig."
Auch selbstbewusst?
Ja, sicher auch.
Und vermutlich auch eher ...
Ich hatte mir diese Sache überlegt,
ich hatte sie mir auch
politisch überlegt.
Aber ich hatte mir sicherlich
weniger Gedanken darum gemacht,
was es medial
für mich bedeuten würde.
Dessen war ich mir in jenem Moment
nicht voll bewusst.
Guten Morgen, Frau Bundesrätin.
Willkommen.
Schön, mit dir arbeiten zu dürfen.
Bienvenue a ta place.
Meine Freude war gross,
als eine zweite Frau kam.
Denn so sahen unsere Kollegen,
dass Frauen
sehr unterschiedlich sein können.
Es gibt nicht  d i e  Frau.
Wir verstanden uns sehr, sehr gut.
Eine Linke und eine Bürgerliche.
Beide kämpfen aktiv
für die Mutterschaftsversicherung.
Eine Verfassungsbestimmung
seit Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs.
Doch die Männer im Bundesrat
haben sie nie umgesetzt.
Das schlimmste Argument
in meinen Augen war immer:
Im Grunde genommen müssen Frauen
ja zu Hause bleiben, basta.
Und das ist der Grund
für all die gescheiterten Versuche.
Wie zuvor: Auch die beiden Frauen
scheitern an der Urne.
Nach der Niederlage sagten wir:
"Okay, am Sonntagabend
können wir das verdauen,
am Montag
nehmen wir es wieder in die Hand
und versuchen es ein zweites Mal -
oder ein drittes oder viertes Mal."
"Bis es läuft."
Wir haben mit Ruth Metzler
in die Wege geleitet,
dass wir, wenn die Abstimmung
nicht erfolgreich sein würde,
sofort einen anderen Vorschlag
machen würden.
Ich kann zufrieden sein.
Jetzt ist es da.
Im Jahr 2004 stimmt
das Schweizer Volk schliesslich zu:
14 Wochen lang erhalten nun
die Mütter 80 % ihres letzten Lohnes.
Zurück zu Elisabeth Kopp.
Morgen miteinander.
Das ist dein Platz.
Willkommen.
- Danke.
Damals war der Bundesrat
ein reines Männergremium.
Sie dürfen versichert sein, dass die
männlichen Mitglieder des Bundesrats
Sie mit Freude und rückhaltlos
aufnehmen und auch integrieren.
Elisabeth Kopp -
eine Ausnahmeerscheinung.
Sie startet früh
eine politische Karriere,
und der freisinnigen Politikerin
gelingt,
was anderen Frauen
lange verwehrt bleibt:
Sie wird von einem öffentlichen Amt
ins andere gewählt.
Das war mein Los,
ich war überall, in all diesen
Gremien die erste und einzige Frau.
Im Gemeinderat,
als Gemeindepräsidentin sowieso,
im Bildungsrat
und zum Schluss im Bundesrat.
Für uns alle ist es ein
riesiger Höhepunkt, dass wir heute
Frau Bundesrätin Elisabeth Kopp
unter uns haben dürfen.
Im Bundesrat setzt sie sich als
Erstes für ein neues Eherecht ein.
Partnerschaft statt Paschatum.
Das ist das Motto
der Eherechtsrevision.
Das neue Eherecht deshalb als ehe-
und familienfeindlich zu bezeichnen,
ist ebenso absurd
wie die Behauptung,
Demokratie sei staatsfeindlich.
Ich legte mich ins Zeug
für das neue Eherecht.
Vom Genfer- bis zum Bodensee,
vom Tessin bis in den Jura
war ich jeden Abend unterwegs.
Und am nächsten Tag um 7 Uhr
wieder im Büro.
Für Sie war die Gleichberechtigung
von Frau und Mann wichtig.
Ja, sehr.
Das ist das A und das O.
Wenn ich mir vorstelle, dass mir
mein Mann hätte verbieten können,
in den Bundesrat zu gehen,
ich müsse seine Einwilligung haben -
das ist doch so absurd.
Und der Mann
legte auch den Wohnsitz fest.
Die Frau brauchte sein Einver-
ständnis, wenn sie arbeiten wollte.
Das sind doch Ungeheuerlichkeiten.
Warum waren Sie so stark
auf Frauenthemen sensibilisiert?
Aus Gerechtigkeitsgründen,
aus Gleichberechtigungsgründen.
Es gab so einzelne Dinge.
Der Rektor liess mich mal kommen ...
Ich war in Bern im Gymnasium.
Und er fragte mich,
was ich eigentlich an einem lite-
rarischen Gymnasium verloren hätte.
Für mehr als eine Eisrevue
würde ich sowieso nicht taugen.
Ich nähme bloss
einem begabten Jungen den Platz weg.
Hätte er gesagt,
ich nehme jemandem den Platz weg,
der mehr für die Schule arbeitet,
dann wäre das okay gewesen.
Ich hatte meine Prioritäten,
zumindest im Winter, anders gesetzt.
Elisabeth Kopp -
die preisgekrönte Eiskunstläuferin.
Trotzdem schliesst sie
ihr Jus-Studium
mit der Höchstnote
summa cum laude ab.
Mit Elisabeth Kopp haben nun
die Frauen im Bundesrat eine Stimme.
Doch sie bleiben in der Minderheit.
Als Bundesrätin
erntet sie auch Kritik.
* Buhrufe *
(Frau)
Die andere Schweiz grüsst Frau Kopp.
Sie gilt als Hardlinerin
und polarisiert
mit einer restriktiven Asylpolitik.
Der Bundesrat und alle
an diesen Entscheiden Mitbeteiligten
empfinden nicht weniger
Menschlichkeit als Sie.
Aber im Gegensatz zu Ihnen
tragen wir auch langfristig
die Verantwortung.
Auch Ruth Metzler wird
mit der Asylfrage konfrontiert.
Ihr Amtsantritt fällt
mitten in die Kosovo-Krise.
50'000 Menschen
flüchten in die Schweiz.
Sie werden vorübergehend aufgenommen
und sollen nach Kriegsende
wieder zurück.
Ruth Metzler informiert sich vor Ort.
Meine Eindrücke,
die ich bekommen habe,
v.a. aus den Gesprächen,
die ich geführt habe,
sind so, dass es
die Sicherheitslage erlaubt,
mit der Rückkehr
weiterfahren zu können,
nicht nur mit der freiwilligen,
sondern auch mit der zwangsweisen.
Linke Nationalrätinnen
werfen ihr vor,
sie würde die humanitäre Tradition
der Schweiz verletzen.
Die heftige Ablehnung überrascht
die junge Bundesrätin und trifft sie.
Die Schwierigkeit war,
dass man von einer Frau
eher erwartete,
dass sie bei diesen Themen
mehr sozial, mehr links ist.
Und wenn sie es nicht ist,
dann ist sie keine richtige Frau.
Das war vor 20 Jahren doch noch
ein bisschen anders als heute.
Elisabeth Kopp
ist seit vier Jahren im Bundesrat,
als sich die Ereignisse überstürzen.
Eine Schlagzeile jagt die andere.
Es geht um ihren Mann.
Sie soll Insiderwissen an ihn weiter-
gegeben haben, um ihn zu warnen -
vor einem drohenden Verfahren
wegen Geldwäscherei.
Die Stimmung war so aufgeblasen.
Was für mich
schwer nachvollziehbar war:
Diese Bundesräte kannten
meinen Mann schliesslich auch.
Sie kannten mich gut.
Dass sie überhaupt
auf die Idee gekommen waren,
dass wir so etwas getan hätten.
Das war für mich
nicht nachvollziehbar.
Zum Verhängnis wird ihr,
dass sie einen Telefonanruf
an ihren Mann zunächst leugnet.
Das war vielleicht ein Fehler.
Aber ich hatte ja
kein schlechtes Gewissen.
Ich hatte
kein Amtsgeheimnis verletzt,
mein Mann wusste das alles schon.
Das war wahrscheinlich einfach
der Funke ins Dynamit.
Der Druck wird zu gross.
Elisabeth Kopp
gibt ihren Rücktritt bekannt.
Die Verdächtigungen
und Unterstellungen,
nicht allein gegen meine Familie,
sondern jetzt auch
gegen mich selbst,
haben zunehmend einen Grad
und eine Dimension erreicht,
die untragbar sind.
Am 12. Januar 1989 verlässt
Elisabeth Kopp das Bundeshaus.
Die erste Bundesrätin,
öffentlich gedemütigt und zerstört.
Wie haben Sie das ausgehalten?
Damals gab es noch keine Netze
an der Kirchenfeldbrücke.
Entschuldigung?
Ich will sagen,
ich hatte mir überlegt ...
Damals nahmen sich
sehr viele Menschen das Leben,
indem sie
von der Kirchenfeldbrücke sprangen.
Dann wurden Netze angebracht.
Aber damals gab es noch keine.
Damit ist alles gesagt.
Das hatten Sie sich überlegt?
- Ja.
So verzweifelt?
Ich ertrage keine Ungerechtigkeit.
Auch nicht,
wenn sie anderen widerfährt.
Nach vier Jahren als Bundesrätin
wird Ruth Metzler abgewählt.
Sie stand ohne Hausmacht
in der eigenen Partei da.
Ja, ich würde sagen,
in gewisser Weise
hat man sie über Bord geworfen,
als man fand, zwei CVP-Bundesräte,
das sei jetzt Geschichte.
Und das ist unfair.
Gewählt ist mit 121 Stimmen ...
- Est elu avec 121 voix ...
... Herr Nationalrat
Christoph Blocher.
Ich habe immer gewusst, es gibt
ein Leben nach dem Bundesrat.
Dass es bereits jetzt beginnt,
hätte ich mir anders gewünscht.
Wieder gibt es Proteste.
Bei ihrer Abwahl,
sagt Ruth Metzler heute,
waren damals
auch die Frauen mitentscheidend.
Wenn man schaut, wie knapp es war:
Es waren drei Stimmen, die fehlten.
Und wenn mich
alle Frauen unterstützt hätten,
dann wäre ich heute nicht mehr
Bundesrätin, behaupte ich mal,
aber ich wäre noch ein paar Jahre
Bundesrätin gewesen.
Das wären Sie gerne gewesen?
Das wäre ich gerne gewesen.
Ich bin nicht freiwillig gegangen.
# A l'eglise, beau petit homme,
demain tu seras baptise.
# Une cloche sonne, sonne.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
mit dem Publikum auf eine andere
Weise kommunizieren zu können.
Weitab der Politik, auf eine
viel persönlichere emotionalere Art.
Die Musik
gehörte immer zu meinem Leben.
Meine erste musikalische Erinnerung
ist die Blasmusik an den Fron-
leichnamfeiern oder am 1. August.
Und das Eidg. Turnfest,
wo ich bei den Jungturnerinnen war.
Wir übten
auf einem grossen Fussballfeld
eingerahmt von Blasmusik -
das ist mir geblieben.
Micheline Calmy-Rey
ist die vierte Frau im Bundesrat.
Ich bringe meine Wurzeln,
meine welsche Kultur,
mein Leben
als Mutter und Grossmutter
und mein Engagement
für die sozial Benachteiligten mit.
Was wird sich im Bundesrat ändern,
wenn eine Grossmutter da ist?
Was werden Sie einbringen?
Nehmen Sie die Enkel mit
an die Bundesratssitzung?
Da gibt es nichts zu lachen.
Die Frauen, die Kinder haben,
haben ein sehr schweres Leben.
Sie arbeiten,
sie haben Kinder zu erziehen.
Und es gibt nicht genug Plätze,
um die Kinder zu hüten.
Das ist ein richtiges Problem,
das ist ein schwieriges Leben.
Manchmal
ist es auch finanziell schwierig.
Ich habe dieses Leben gekannt.
Und meine Tochter kennt es auch.
Micheline Calmy-Rey
et Alexandra Calmy, bonjour.
Die Erinnerung, die ich habe,
ist der Schreibtisch,
der in der Mitte der Wohnung stand.
Mein Mutter wollte präsent sein.
Ich konnte die Dinge
nicht einfach laufen lassen.
Ich glaube, das habe ich auch
geerbt, im Guten oder im Schlechten.
Die Arbeit, das ist wahr, ist ein
Wert, den du uns vermittelt hast.
Gab es Streit?
Konfrontation, ja.
Sie ist sehr autoritär.
Ich habe gelernt, damit zu leben.
Sie scheinen auch autoritär zu sein.
- Ich hoffe, nicht so sehr.
Mein Massstab ist,
wenn meine Töchter sagen:
"Mach es nicht so wie Grossmutter!"
Die Frau, die heute im Zentrum
steht, lässt niemanden kalt.
Und ihre Aussenpolitik
macht Schlagzeilen.
Im Jahr 2008 trägt sie
bei einem Empfang durch den
iranischen Präsidenten ein Kopftuch.
Ein unnötiger Kniefall, heisst es.
Sehen Sie, es ist viel leichter,
zu Hause im Sessel zu sitzen
und zu kritisieren.
Es ist viel schwieriger, dort hin-
zugehen und zu sagen, Auge in Auge:
"Hören Sie, Herr Präsident,
es ist nicht akzeptabel,
dass Sie
das Existenzrecht Israels leugnen."
Es ist ein kleiner Schritt.
Ich bin sehr glücklich,
diese Diskussion beginnen zu können.
Die alte, traditionelle
Neutralitätspolitik darf nicht
durch Aktivismus einmal diesen
und einmal jenen verärgern.
Es gibt keine Aussenpolitik
von Calmy-Rey.
Es gibt eine Aussenpolitik
der Schweiz.
Die Aussenpolitik der Schweiz wird
umgesetzt vom Bundesrat, vom EDA.
Sie haben einen Charakter,
einen eher starken Charakter.
Na, hören Sie,
das ist doch eher eine Qualität,
wenn man in einer Regierung sitzt.
Im Jahr 2007:
Eveline Widmer-Schlumpf
steht vor einer grossen Entscheidung.
Sie ist als Bundesrätin gewählt,
Christoph Blocher ist abgewählt.
Wird sie Ja sagen,
wird sie die Wahl akzeptieren?
Die ganze Schweiz wartet gespannt.
Ja oder nein?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich bin zu 80-85 % überzeugt,
dass sie Ja sagen wird.
Ich hoffe sehr, dass sie Ja sagt
und dass sie den Parlamentsentscheid
höher gewichtet
als den Druck aus ihrer Partei,
auch wenn er brutal hoch ist.
Sie haben, geschätzte Damen und
Herren, mir mit dieser Wahl gestern
eine grosse Aufgabe, eine
grosse Verantwortung übertragen.
Ich kann dieser nur gerecht werden,
diese nur wahrnehmen,
wenn ich
auf Ihre Unterstützung zählen darf.
Geschätzte Damen und Herren,
wenn wir in diesem Saal
in Sachfragen auch immer wieder
unterschiedliche Meinungen haben,
so lassen Sie uns doch einander
stets
mit Respekt und Toleranz begegnen.
In diesem Sinne
erkläre ich Annahme der Wahl.
Gottverdammt noch mal!
Judas! Judas!
Herr Blocher, was sagen Sie ...
- Machen Sie Platz!
Dieser Vorwurf trifft mich.
Der Vorwurf,
ich hätte die Parteileitung,
das Volk und alle angelogen.
Das trifft mich.
Vor wenigen Wochen:
Eveline Widmer-Schlumpf erzählt,
weshalb sie in die Politik einstieg.
Mir wurde es 1971
zum ersten Mal richtig bewusst.
Ich war 15 Jahre alt, Gymnasiastin.
Ich dachte,
Frauen und Männer sind gleich.
Bei mir gab es
kein anderes Weltbild.
Ich bin mit zwei Schwestern in einem
totalen Frauenhaushalt aufgewachsen.
Mein Papa sagte immer, sogar
der Hund sei bei uns weiblich.
Für mich gab es bis dahin
diese Diskussion gar nicht.
Und ich war auf der Strasse
und sah mit Entsetzen Plakate:
"Männer, bewahrt uns
vor dem Frauenstimmrecht!"
Ich dachte, mich trifft der Schlag.
Ich war entsprechend aufgebracht,
aber am nächsten Tag sah ich
eine grosse Gruppe von Frauen
aus verschiedenen
Frauenorganisationen,
auch politische,
das ganze Spektrum,
und ich sah,
wie diese Frauen hinstanden.
Das machte mir Spass.
Und da dachte ich,
ich möchte mich auch für diese
Natürlichkeit - alle sind gleich -
einsetzen.
Die Abstimmung wurde dann gewonnen,
wir haben
das Frauenstimmrecht erhalten.
Mein Papa hatte sich
gewaltig dafür eingesetzt,
und man machte ihm den Vorwurf,
er hätte das nur gemacht, weil er
zu Hause "nur" drei Mädchen habe.
Das hat mich noch viel mehr gefreut,
das können Sie sich vorstellen.
Nach der Abstimmung sagte er mir -
das hatte ich immer in den Ohren:
"So, die rechtlichen Grundlagen
haben wir jetzt,
jetzt müsst ihr Frauen selbst dafür
sorgen, dass es umgesetzt wird."
Und das wollte ich tatsächlich auch.
1971 -
die ersten Frauen im Parlament:
Josi Meier,
Hedi Lang
und Lilian Uchtenhagen.
(Mann)
Verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass Sie
eine grosse Reihe von Aufgaben
mindestens so gut werden
bearbeiten können wie wir Männer.
Ihr müsst uns einweisen.
Ja, wir machen das so.
Unser Fotograf
streckt die Hand hoch.
Vor wenigen Tagen:
Doris Leuthard posiert mit Frauen
der Allianz F für ein Gruppenfoto.
Cheese!
Für Bundesrätin Leuthard war die
CVP-Nationalrätin Josi Meier wichtig.
Sie war auch Juristin.
Sie war so eine kleine, mutige,
eigentlich total freche Frau
für ihre Generation.
Sie hat sich
extrem viel Respekt erarbeitet,
einfach weil sie argumentieren
und diesen Männern sagen konnte:
"Das stimmt, das stimmt nicht,
das ist falsch."
Sie liess sich auf die Debatte ein
und ging aber gleichzeitig mit ihnen
ein Bier trinken, war gesellig.
Mich hat immer beeindruckt,
dass so ein Umgang dazu führte,
dass sie respektiert wurde.
Das Geschlecht
spielte keine Rolle mehr,
aber eine extreme Mutmacherin.
Sie war ja auch diejenige
mit dem Spruch:
"Frauen gehören ins Haus ...
ins Bundeshaus."
Das war für mich so prägend,
dass ich gesagt habe:
"Eigentlich kannst du nicht kneifen,
du musst auch mal Ja sagen."
Ich schwöre es.
Hören Sie auf mit Märchen, kümmern
Sie sich um die echten Zahlen.
* Das Ferkel quiekt. *
Als ich für den Bundesrat
kandidierte, hiess es zunächst:
"Kann die das?
Führungsfähigkeiten etc."
Und als Frau
hinterfragt man sich immer sofort.
Man hat dann auch das Gefühl:
"Huch!", man bekommt Skrupel.
Und das sind so Phasen,
und ich muss bis heute immer wieder
fragen: "Okay, wage ich das?"
Die Medien stehen dann sehr schnell
wieder bereit und sagen:
"Ah, habt ihr gesehen?
Sie hat Emotionen gezeigt."
Ich bin nahe am Wasser gebaut.
Das wird sofort zu einem Problem:
"Kann die überhaupt Präsidentin sein
oder eine Aufgabe wahrnehmen?"
"Sie hat Emotionen."
Das sind so Klischees, die belasten.
Von daher sind wir z.T.
sehr kritisch uns selbst gegenüber
und reduzieren unsere Fähigkeiten,
statt auszuprobieren und zu sagen:
"Okay, ich mute mir das zu."
Und solche Phasen
hatte ich natürlich auch.
Gut.
Ich habe mich immer gefragt:
"Kann ich das?"
Schon beim ersten Mal, als es
um das Bezirksrichteramt ging,
stellte ich mir die Frage:
"Es gibt so viele Bezirksrichter,
die keine Juristen sind -
wieso sollte ich das nicht können?"
Ja, und bis und mit Regierungsrätin
lief es so weiter.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass ich das
kann, dass ich etwas lernen kann.
Ich lerne schnell.
Und als es um den Bundesrat ging,
fragte ich mich:
"Ist dieser Schritt nicht zu gross?
Tue ich mir da nicht etwas an?"
Sie haben immer noch das Gefühl,
sie müssten noch besser sein.
Dieses Erstklässler-Syndrom
bei den Frauen
ist für mich etwas,
das noch aus Vergangenheit stammt.
Und auch der Eindruck,
dass sie nicht ganz willkommen sind.
Sie sollten das wirklich
an der Tür ablegen.
Sie sollten sich sagen: "Ich habe
das gleiche Recht wie ein Mann."
"Ich muss nicht
noch etwas Zusätzliches bringen."
Der Preis für Männer und für Frauen
muss derselbe sein.
Wenn man die Prozentzahlen
der Frauen anschaut,
im Nationalrat, Ständerat,
Regierungsrat, Bundesrat,
haben wir eine Stagnation.
Gerade in der Wirtschaft
dachten wir,
wir hätten top ausgebildete Frauen,
in gewissen Berufen sogar mehr als
50 % mit akademischer Ausbildung.
Und trotzdem,
wenn man ins obere Management kommt,
sieht es anders aus.
Am stärksten
habe ich es im UVEK erlebt,
wo es technische Bereiche gibt,
viele Ingenieure und Physiker
und Naturwissenschaftler
und ganz wenig Frauen.
Deshalb habe ich dann
immer versucht,
auf die Möglichkeiten, die es gibt,
aufmerksam zu machen
und Frauen
in ihrer Laufbahn zu unterstützen.
Wir haben heute diverse Massnahmen
in unserem Departement eingeleitet
für unsere 2'600 Mitarbeiter.
D.h. mehr Telearbeit,
mehr Teilzeitbeschäftigungsmodelle,
flexiblere, familienfreundliche
Arbeitszeitmodelle,
aber auch einen Vaterschaftsurlaub
mit fünf Tagen werden wir einführen.
* Fröhliche Klaviermelodie *
Simonetta Sommaruga,
die siebte Bundesrätin.
Eine ganz wichtige Zeit
war für mich,
als ich Klavierunterricht gab,
Konzerte gab.
Ich arbeitete nachts in Freiburg
im Haus für geschlagene Frauen.
Ich hatte das Bedürfnis,
mit einem anderen Teil des Lebens
in Kontakt zu kommen.
Was ich dort sah,
die Situationen dieser Frauen:
totale Abhängigkeit,
kein Weiterwissen, kein Geld,
keine Wohnung, keinen Job,
kleine Kinder.
Die totale Aussichtslosigkeit.
Das hat mich stark politisiert,
und ich beschloss, mich für diese
Frauen einzusetzen, auch politisch.
Frau Simonetta Sommaruga.
* Jubelrufe *
Merci.
Wir freuen uns so.
Alle Schweizer Frauen.
Sie könnten
für die Leute dieses Landes
eine Mischung zwischen Lady Di und
Helvetia werden. Belastet Sie das?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Was man in den letzten Wochen
alles über mich gesagt hat,
war manchmal lustig, manchmal
amüsant und manchmal auch bizarr.
Aber damit muss man leben können.
Ich bin die, die ich bin,
und werde mich auch nicht ändern.
Mit ihrer Wahl stellen die Frauen das
erste Mal die Mehrheit im Bundesrat.
Beim Thema Atomstrom
wird das entscheidend sein.
Denn aus der Atomstrom-Befürworterin
Doris Leuthard
wird nach der Fukushima-Katastrophe
eine andere Energiepolitikerin.
Deshalb ist der Bundesrat überzeugt,
dass das Szenario 2,
also ein schrittweiser Ausstieg
aus der Kernenergie,
der richtige Schritt ist
für die Zukunft.
Deshalb denke ich, ist das
durchaus ein historischer Tag.
Es ist ja heute kein Geheimnis mehr:
Es war wirklich eine Frauenmehrheit.
Und sonst, ich weiss nicht,
wie es ausgegangen wäre.
Wenn Sie als Bundesrätin
im Kollegium die Mehrheit haben,
dann ist es einfach,
Sie gehen einfach zurück ins Büro.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen,
es sei ein sehr gutes Jahr gewesen,
als wir die Frauenmehrheit hatten.
Mir gefiel es auch.
Das war etwas, auch im Bundesrat,
wo wir uns immer gefunden haben,
egal aus welcher Partei wir kamen.
Wir merkten: "Das ist richtig.
Jetzt können wir unser Amt nutzen,
um wirklich
einen neuen Weg einzuschlagen
oder einen Entscheid zu fällen,
bei dem man weiss,
es ist vielleicht
mit Widerstand zu rechnen."
Aber wir haben es gemacht,
weil es richtig war.
Das Parlament hingegen ist von einer
Frauenmehrheit weit, weit entfernt.
Simonetta Sommaruga
spürt das bei Frauenanliegen.
Diskriminierung hat sie
als junge Frau selbst erfahren.
Ich hatte einmal eine Stelle,
bei der ich weniger als die Hälfte
verdiente als mein Vorgänger.
Das fand ich allerdings
erst später raus.
Ich wehrte mich dagegen
und es gab eine Veränderung.
Aber das war ein klassischer Fall:
Ich war noch jung,
ich glaubte,
ich müsse die Arbeit gut machen
und erst beweisen,
dass ich das überhaupt kann.
(Alle) Frauen, streikt!
Frauen, streikt!
Eine Veranstaltung, an der
Frauenanliegen thematisiert werden.
Simonetta Sommaruga
ist als Referentin eingeladen.
(Alle) Frauen, streikt!
Sie wird hier
als Schlüsselfigur wahrgenommen,
auch wegen ihres Engagements
für Lohngleichheit im Parlament.
Wenn eine Frau
die gleiche Ausbildung hat,
gleich lang im Unternehmen ist,
den gleichen Job macht
und auch
auf der gleichen Kaderstufe steht,
dann soll sie
gleich viel Lohn erhalten.
Und zwar unabhängig davon,
ob sie früher einmal
drei oder vier Jahre ausgesetzt hat,
weil sie Kinder bekommen hat.
Löhne einfach
eins zu eins zu vergleichen,
gestaltet sich in der Praxis
als sehr schwierig.
Hier wird einmal mehr
regulierend in den liberalen
Arbeitsmarkt eingegriffen.
Aus diesem Grund
empfiehlt Ihnen die SVP-Fraktion,
heute gar nicht erst
auf diese Vorlage einzutreten.
Wir sprechen hier
von einem Verfassungsauftrag
und nicht einem Wunschprogramm.
Zusammengefasst
ist somit klar festzuhalten,
dass diese Lohnanalyse
zwar gut gemeint sein mag,
aber ausser
zusätzlichen Regulierungen
für die Wirtschaft nichts bringt.
Einen Tag Aufwand alle vier Jahre,
meine Damen und Herren,
um ein verfassungsmässiges Recht
auf Lohngleichheit
nach 37 Jahren einzulösen -
ist das zu viel verlangt?
* Jubel, Applaus *
Es ist keine Revolution,
diese Vorlage.
Aber es ist klar, sie wirkt.
Wenn die grossen Firmen alle
vier Jahre diese Analyse machen,
aufzeigen und überprüfen müssen,
ob sie Diskriminierung
in der Firma haben,
dann löst das etwas aus.
Denn dass heute in der Schweiz
Frauen immer noch weniger verdienen,
nur weil sie Frauen sind,
ist ein Skandal.
Als ich in Bundesrat gewählt wurde,
waren wir vier Frauen -
eine Frauenmehrheit.
* Applaus *
Diese für Schweizer Verhältnisse
verrückte Zeit dauerte 14 Monate.
Dann war es vorbei,
heute sind wir zwei.
Und viele finden,
zwei seien doch eigentlich genug.
* Buhrufe *
Es muss uns doch zu denken geben,
wenn wir sehen, dass es
in verschiedenen Kantonsregierungen
keine Frauen mehr gibt.
Kantonsregierungen,
die Frauen hatten.
Tessin, Luzern,
Appenzell Ausserrhoden
und ab 2019 leider auch Graubünden.
Aus heutiger Sicht verstehe ich
alle, die Quoten fordern.
Zumindest vorübergehende.
Wir haben viel zu lange zugeschaut.
Hier spreche ich v.a. die Wirtschaft
an, nicht nur die Politik.
Und im Gegensatz zu vor fünf Jahren
würde ich heute
auch ein Ja in die Urne legen.
Es darf nicht mehr passieren,
dass es nur eine oder zwei sind.
Und nur  e i n e  Bundesrätin
wird es bestimmt nie mehr geben.
Mit Ihrer Geschichte,
können Sie einer Frau überhaupt
empfehlen, diesen Weg zu gehen?
Ich würde jeder Frau sagen,
es sei gut, in die Politik zu gehen,
weil es einfach nötig ist.
Es ist ...
Es gibt einfach eine andere Politik.
Unbedingt kandidieren!
Ich bin überzeugt,
wir brauchen Frauen,
die sagen, was sie möchten,
wie sie die Gesellschaft von morgen
verändern wollen.
Wenn wir das
nur den anderen überlassen,
dann ist es einfach so geprägt,
wie mehrheitlich Männer
sich das vorstellen.
Im Bundesrat wäre es sehr einfach.
Es liegt in den Händen
der Bundesversammlung,
dafür zu sorgen, dass es immer
drei von der einen Sorte
und vier von der anderen Sorte gibt.
Unser Land
hat in Sachen Gleichstellung
jahrzehntelange Verspätung.
Wir müssen täglich einfordern,
dass Macht und Verantwortung
zwischen Frauen und Männern
gerecht verteilt werden.
Wir sind noch lange nicht am Ziel.
Danke.